between their reaction to covid and
their full-on Embrace of gender ideology
nearly every major medical organization
in the country has completely
discredited itself over the past couple
of years I'm not sure that we've really
ever seen an industry so quickly and so
thoroughly torch its own credibility in
this way granted we're facing an
Institutional crisis in the west where
almost all major institutions have
forfeited the Public's trust but the
medical industry sets itself apart
because of the dramatic and seemingly
seemingly sudden nature of its moral and
intellectual collapse and because the
consequences of the public losing
confidence in the medical industry of
all Industries are especially dire
the public may still have faith in
medicine the science of medicine but
they don't trust the people charged with
developing dispensing and prescribing it
and why should they
worst of all the specific area of the
medical field that has conducted itself
the most shamefully and destructively
is that area which deals with children
in particular the American Academy of
Pediatrics which is the largest
Association of Pediatricians in the
country has gotten it disastrously wrong
on every important issue for the past
several years and counting pushing faux
medicine and faux treatments and putting
ideology ahead of science every step of
the way the APA of course pushed school
shutdowns during covid
masking for children even now
recommending the Cova vaccine for six
month old babies that's the apa's
recommendation
and of course it is one of the principal
promoters of gender ideology in the
country giving a rubber stamp to
whatever the extremist World
Professional Association of transgender
Health has to say and as wpath
guidelines recommend castration
mutilation and sterilization for ever
younger gender confused children so too
then does the APA
of all the once respected organizations
that have been ideologically captured by
the far left and become these grotesque
discredited husks of what they once were
the APA perhaps sets itself apart
and it's not done it's not done yet
CBS News has the latest quote children
struggling with obesity should be
evaluated and treated early and
aggressively including with medications
for kids as young as 12 and surgery for
those as young as 13 according to new
guidelines released on Monday the
long-standing practice of watchful
waiting or delaying treatment to see
whether children and teens outgrow or
overcome obesity on their own only
worsens worsens the problem that affects
more than 14.4 million young people in
the U.S researchers say left untreated
obesity can lead to lifelong health
problems including high blood pressure
diabetes and depression waiting doesn't
work said Dr ihuma ineli co-author of
the guidance on childhood obesity in 15
years from on the first guidance on
childhood obesity in 15 years from the
American Academy of Pediatrics what we
see is a continuation of weight gain and
the likelihood that they'll have obesity
and adulthood
For the First Time The group's guidance
sets ages at which kids and teens should
be offered Medical Treatments such as
drugs and surgery in addition to
intensive diet exercise and other
behavior and lifestyle interventions
said in Le director of the center for
health healthy weight and nutrition at
Nationwide Children's Hospital in
general doctors should offer adolescents
12 and older who have obesity access to
appropriate drugs and teens 13 and older
with severe obesity referrals for weight
loss surgery those situations may vary
so as we've seen the APA loves nothing
more in this world than performing
medically unnecessary and potentially
dangerous elective surgeries on children
who cannot consent to them or fully
understand their long-term ramifications
it's like their favorite thing to do
apparently they aren't you know able to
get their fix with just gender
transition surgeries and so so now
they've moved over to the area of
obesity
and and what sort of supposedly extreme
situations might warrant weight loss
surgeries for minors well CBS news also
provides a helpful example and uh and
let's listen
Rose Garcia says for as long as she can
remember doctors told her she was
overweight what did the doctor or others
tell you to do just to exercise and eat
better she struggled unsuccessfully for
years then at age 15 she developed
hypertension and became pre-diabetic I
visited my doctor and I told her that I
wanted to lose weight but I wanted help
I knew I couldn't do it by myself with
parental permission she finally tried
bariatric weight loss surgery last June
along with counseling for emotional
eating since then she has lost more than
90 pounds did you look in the mirror and
think who is that my clothing was a big
big sign I would put on my carrot
dresses and they were too big and it was
really really surprising to me the new
guidelines from the AAP recommend better
nutrition exercise and face-to-face
counseling treatment may also include
weight loss drugs and surgery for
adolescents who meet the criteria but
for many families medication and surgery
are not covered by Ensure parents if
they have insurance what do you think
about these new guidelines I think that
it's
definitely step in the right direction
step in the right direction
but we gotta we have to operate on even
more kids
now you notice a couple of things about
the girl in that clip if you're watching
on the video podcast the first is that
she was not morbidly obese at least when
she was especially when she was younger
the show pictures of her when she was a
younger child uh they said well she's
been struggling with her weights and she
was a very young child
they show the picture she was chubby
moderately overweight
the kind of overweight that can be quite
easily handled with modest diet changes
and a reasonable amount of exercise
it's very easy to deal with
second she says that that doctors
initially told her to eat healthy and
exercise but she doesn't say that she
actually followed those recommendations
you know so and and we know that she
didn't because anyone anyone who eats
healthy and gets exercise will not be
overweight
okay that's the case for every person on
Earth and if you're listening to this
saying I'm an exception to that no
you're not
okay if you if you if you eat less than
you're eating now and you eat better
than you're eating now and you get more
exercise than you're getting right now
you will lose weight you will everyone
will
now we hear a lot about alleged hormone
issues and other medical complications
that cause people to gain weight
uncontrollably and yet the fact remains
that eating less food or better food
will result in less fat on your body
this is a matter of simple science and
it's the reason why most third world
countries do not have an obesity
epidemic
the people don't eat a lot of food in
those countries and therefore they don't
get fat if it was if it was possible
that genetics or hormones could make you
morbidly obese regardless of what you
eat
then we should be we should see starving
450 pound Ethiopians but we don't
weight gain is a simple formula if you
consume more calories than you burn you
will gain weight if you burn more
calories than you consume you will lose
weight
it's not complicated
and therefore losing weight is not
complicated
though it may be difficult
there's a difference between difficult
and complicated
difficult not because there's any sort
of complex math equation involved but
simply because developing healthy habits
requires discipline and discipline
requires effort and effort can be hard
especially in a culture that encourages
laziness
effort is always at least going to be
harder than no effort
okay the easiest thing is to put in no
effort
and the the the difficulty level will
increase with each extra bit of effort
you apply
difficult not complicated
living a healthy life
in any sense of the word healthy
physically healthy mentally healthy
spiritually is difficult in our society
especially but there is no substitute
for just doing the difficult thing
either you will do it and have the life
you wish to have or not
I mean it's your choice it is your
choice
and in the end there is nothing a doctor
can do to compensate for your refusal to
make the right choices
or rather if there is something they can
do to compensate the negative
consequences in the long run will vastly
outweigh puns slightly intended the
benefits
now every doctor in the country
and every member of the APA knows that
everything I've said so far is true they
know that anyone can lose weight with a
healthy lifestyle they know that the
Obesity epidemic is an epidemic of
people living unhealthy Lifestyles
choosing unhealthy lifestyles
or if their children were talking about
very often these are Lifestyles being
chosen for them
their parents feeding them garbage
putting them on a couch with video games
and TV and whatever and screens
yeah and and again
every doctor knows that all of this is
true yet they have embraced the Obesity
as a disease model of care anyway where
the fat person is treated as though his
fatness was inflicted upon him through
no fault of his own
rather than telling the the parent of
the obese child that they should feed
him better food
instead they now treat the obese child
as though his obesity is a virus or a
cancer
as though it is something that he you
know like contracted
an illness inflicted upon him which
which must now be surgically removed
like a like a tumor
the important thing to understand is
that the medical professionals involved
in instituting this change of approach
they know that their reasoning is bogus
they know it they went to medical school
they know why people get fat
they know how people get unfat
just like they know the difference
between males and females and how binary
and immutable those identities are but
they're now operating within their
medical field as if they do not know
these things
this is a philosophical decision
and we must understand what the
philosophy is
the medical field has long since decided
and this goes back many years okay so
it's actually not just in the last
couple of years it goes back many years
the medical field decided that human
beings are helpless automatons with no
free will no capacity to make choices
are to change and no agency over their
own lives
okay that is the that is the assumption
that the medical field as a as a whole
operates on
it is an industry run by extreme
materialists who believe essentially
that the human mind basically doesn't
exist certainly the soul does not exist
we are the product of chemical reactions
we are governed by these reactions
entirely and so literally any problem we
have anything we suffer from can be
solved chemically that's the way they
look at it this is a process that has
been ongoing for decades and it began
principally in the psychiatric industry
where every bad habit is an addiction
now and every addiction is a disease and
every uncomfortable or inconvenient
human emotion or behavior is a mental
illness and every mental illness is a
disease
the psychiatrists have spent decades
cataloging and medicalizing the entire
Human Condition prescribing psychotropic
drugs to treat everyone who behaves in a
way that falls slightly outside the norm
the norm as defined and determined by
them the psychiatrist
they have done this for so long with
almost no resistance from the public
and mostly because the public has bought
into the program
or been drugged into it as the case may
be
the psychiatrists have been lying to us
but for many people it's a comforting
lie it's a convenient lie it's a lie
that absolves the individual of all
responsibility
if you're doing something you shouldn't
be doing and you're destroying your life
and your family in the process it's only
because you're addicted and it's not
your fault because it's a disease and if
you're experiencing difficult emotions
well then take a drug and get rid of
them because human beings are not
supposed to feel those sorts of feelings
all of this rests you know all of this
rests on a on a whole precarious pile of
philosophical claims and assumptions
that make no sense and that fall apart
under the slightest scrutiny but most
people do not scrutinize them because
they're afraid of the burden of personal
responsibility they'll end up with if
they reject the psychiatric industry's
claims
now
that's psychiatry
my point here is simply that when you
start seeing doctors prescribing diet
pills and gastric bypass surgeries for
chubby 13 year olds treating their
obesity like a cancer that cannot be
cured anyway except with medical
interventions you should know that this
sort of extreme medicalization of The
Human Condition this this uh treating
human beings like pre-programmed robots
who cannot be expected to change their
behavior this has all been going on for
a very long time
and the stage has been set for many
years
and the average American tragically has
gone along with it up until now
there may reach a point I think we've
already reached the point
where the average American starts to
object
but the question is
whether it's simply too late
and I will do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]